life-science biosensor diagnostics
incorporated a member of the IQ group
global presents the saliva glucose
biosensor diabetes is recognized as the
world's fastest-growing chronic disease
one in 11 people has diabetes
that's 415 million people every six
seconds a person dies from diabetes five
hundred and forty two thousand children
have type 1 diabetes 12 percent of
global health expenditure is spent on
diabetes six hundred and seventy three
billion u.s. dollars the global market
for glucose monitoring devices is
expected to grow from 10 billion u.s.
dollars in 2015 to twelve point four
billion u.s. dollars in 2020 by 2040 it
is estimated one in ten will have
diabetes that's six hundred and forty
two million people diabetes related
health expenditure will exceed eight
hundred and two billion US dollars blood
glucose monitoring is essential when
managing diabetes it helps patients
understand the link between blood
glucose food exercise and their diabetes
medication
affective diabetes monitoring relies on
obtaining numerous daily blood samples
from finger pricks that are invasive
painful and inconvenient patients
families and doctors want a monitoring
system that is non-invasive pain-free
quick and reliable introducing the novel
saliva glucose biosensor system what is
a biosensor
a device that monitors and transmits
information about a biological process
the glucose biosensor consists of an
organic thin film transistor which
integrates glucose oxidase and reacts
with salivary glucose resulting in
hydrogen peroxide which is decomposed
into proton ions generating an
electrical signal this signal is then
processed by a smart device the glucose
biosensor measures glucose in saliva
enabling mobile monitoring that is pain
free quick and accurate the technology
offers patients caregivers and
healthcare professionals the ability to
track store and share health data
revolutionising diabetes care what
starts here changes the world